hey guys I would introduce you to a lady
food pantry a harder with maybe doing it
to be in a moment this is actually
inside my kitchen
she's fine that should be Fred making
four thousand Panama soon to be a
thousand Panama and it's a major story
so watch until the end so I'll be try
get your manners Wednesday Fridays I've
been avoiding it although we've been
talking a lot you are a property owner
with seven houses yeah
financially free yeah and you came to
the crash course literally like two
years ago tell me what happened well I
went to I think it was a crash course
back in sort of September 2017 it was a
long time ago so it was quite a long
time and while I was on the crash course
you talked about that you read where you
live yeah and while I was sat there I
just thought what is this about this
just sounds crazy what is this guy
talking about and I actually went to you
in the break I don't know whether you
remember and I came up to you and I said
why do you rent where you live and then
you explained to me you know why would I
want to put you know huge amounts of
deposit down if you know I live in a
barn and I'd have to put X amount down
in order to buy it and you know it gives
me the flexibility and I can invest that
money into something else
and actually on the break at the crash
course so I went and started looking at
houses that I could rent for you know a
lot nicer than where I'm living and I
think she went home and I said to my
husband I said you know I explained the
situation and he was like oh that's
crazy
and then it kind of like sort of sowed
the seed and it was kind of in the back
of my mind that actually it's a really
good idea because at the time you know
we had quite a bit of equity in our
house and I did look at refinancing
after crash course but you know because
of like you know income and stuff they'd
only give a certain amount and I thought
well that's not really going to get me
very far so then in
a few months later I was diagnosed with
breast cancer so kind of put everything
on hold for a while because then I was
kind of concentrating on my health and
you know I had to have an operation and
treatment and stuff like that so kind of
put everything on hold but at the same
time it gave me the kind of the kick to
think right I really need to go for this
because you know you don't know how long
you've got on this earth you know you
need to if you you know if you want to
do something you kind of need to go for
it so we decided then to sell the house
where we lived and yeah so we put it for
sale in it was about when was it about
March 2018 and then we went to another
crash course being like my husband and
you know for him to have more of an
understanding of what it was about and
stuff like that and he says let this
lets you know sign up for the DfE so I
went along and I did the DfE in between
kind of my treatment yeah crazy time so
I was everything was up in the air
because I kind of wanted to do what I
wanted to do but at the same time I had
my health to kind of you know it was
kind of holding me back I find that even
at the crash course I remember you
you can't you've been to the
Baskervilles more than once yeah
nobody's saying you know I want it I
want to do some advanced training I
wonder the day hey I have got cancer I
know and for me it was really like jeez
yeah I don't even want to advise you or
say oh do they train oh yeah because I
thinking you've got much bigger fish to
fry and to worry about so I was trying
to mentor you and give you advise to
help on the property side but also been
really mindful that actually whilst I
want you to be financially set up this
is just kind of second right yeah we
spoke back and forth quite a lot yeah we
did if I snuck over that whole period of
time and it was just you know it was
just a really even for me it was quite
it made me think a lot yeah
difficult time and I spoke to Russell as
well when he was like you know like you
know which won't work with you and
obviously then I did the DfE and feel
funny yeah a very advanced yeah and I
learned so much you know those three
days and I kind of came away from that
you know it was kind of a lot more
in-depth than the crap the crash chord
and I came away and at the time I think
what I learned from that is the house
that I bought in Wolverhampton this is
before the classroom yeah yeah the house
I bought a house in Wolverhampton in it
was probably about June 17 just before I
went to the car watching the videos no
this was no this was just kind of like a
buy a house in Wolverhampton 22-hour who
taught you or who showed you or inspired
you to buy that or did you do your own
back and well what happened was the IT
cuz I was kind of watching the housing
market in Birmingham at the time and
that came right prices are shooting up
there you know I think it's a really
good place to do best and in ironically
you know this repossession came up in
Wolverhampton and then we lost out on it
and then you know when all the stamp
duty was coming in and I was like
bathroom and then it was like oh you
know need to try and buy you know to try
and get things you know before then and
stuff and there was a bit of pressure so
anyway I ended up buying this house and
then after going on the crash course I
thought that's probably not a great
house that I thought and it and what I
learned from it it's not just about you
know buying a house and rinsing out
there's a lot more to it than that yeah
and and ironically now I've sold that
house in Wolverhampton yeah I mean yeah
we spoke you know so yeah and it was
like it's not it wasn't a good house you
know and it yeah and this is something
you talked about a lot you know it's not
about what the house looks like you know
some people can be you know and I find
it or not in my job as well people are
sort of blinded by all this looks so
lovely you know lovely house you know
it's really bright you know pretty and
you know the flats really nice and
they're kind of blinded by all these
things
yeah so I see all the time in my job you
know they
looking at oh yeah that looks really
nice let's buy it and rinse it out but
obviously there's a lot more to it than
that yeah so yeah so as a sign ends up
selling that one so you came to the
crash course yeah bought one house in
Wolverhampton which is actually not
great bye yeah and you had you were
living in your house and you had a lot
of equity in the house yeah so then you
came to the crash course your husband
he's a police officer
yeah so he's quite you know different
not like probably the way I think good
man because I think the police and stuff
away it's very much you know I have a
pensioner yeah you know worked really
hard and really long so at the crash
course at what point were you like you
know what this could actually make me a
long mother when did you realise because
I don't now you do really wait when did
you realize actually I think it was when
I kind of went away from that crash
course and then sort of started working
out with the equity that we had yeah
what I could use that to invest in and
how much money would make me on a
monthly basis whereas you know obviously
having X amount tied up in one house
than you'll just like paying a mortgage
and yeah by the end of it obviously
you've paid off your mortgage and you
know you're living where you live but it
wasn't gonna accelerate the kind of the
process kind of where I needed it to be
and it to go so so I just thought let's
do this so that's kind of what I did and
okay
so you came onto the deal finding
Australia cancer yeah you loved it yeah
you had your you had your cancer and
everything we kept in touch a lot what
happened there so I had so I had my
operation in May and then I went to
Mexico for treatment towards the end of
the year and then like I had you all
clear not all my scans will clear they
never set up with cancer it's not like
oh you're like cancer free they kind of
say you're in remission so I'm always
very mindful of of that and I think
that's what's made me just want to kind
of go for that everybody
everybody's always got the potential of
getting something yeah or even or even
dying and and when you were given the
not all all clear okay yeah what you had
to count to the had isn't yet on I
remember we spoke he was just like
really yeah and yes it is
and you know obviously have setbacks
where you know I've I've had friends
that we'd kind of met up and we've
diagnosed the same time and they've
recently died and you know you and and
that can be quite difficult yeah because
you just think you know can it happen to
me is it gonna happen to me so you've
always got that worried so I think one
thing that cancer has taught me apart
from it obviously been a really negative
thing is to you know something you know
people in life they just kind of like
poke along and just kind of do their
thing and it's just made me want to
really go for what I'm doing and learn
as much as I can you know I what sure
got your videos like podcast you know
read books and all the time I kind of
like immerse myself and as much like
information like to learn all the time
yeah so I can grow and yeah it's been
difficult you know the last so you know
it's kind of not gone and this is why
Neeson why'd you go to Windows on
Wednesday for and it's not gone as quick
as I hoped it would because you know
that my house that I bought in Blackpool
took about just over a year it's
complete I know it's a yeah and and the
you know the stress of that you know
because it was a commercial sale it was
quite in debt yeah and actually on the
day after completion it was crazy
because I thought oh I don't need to be
found in the solicitor's anymore and it
was not quite free you know it's like it
become part of you richly for a year but
you know what though sometimes things
can take a long time and as frustrating
as it is that is part of the business
no no you've had that you've out and
you've either you know you
she's about issues of tenants yeah
probably
you've got boilers breaking yeah so
you've gone three in one year right so
you've had you've had that but then also
right now how much how much profit you
make you these months so at the moment
currently one house of we're doing a
seven bed HMO so we're having a double
storage site extension to make that
seven bed HTM over six bathrooms so
currently we're making about 4200 on the
properties at the moment currently right
now yeah what 4,200 is your profit yeah
yeah I'm sort of mortgages and things
yeah oh yes a four thousand use your
profit right now however once you get
this few things soiled it with the with
the planning and stuff like that which
you well yeah what's your profit gonna
be it'll be about eight thousand which
is amazing yeah I mean eight thousand a
month coming from property mmm worth the
headaches that you've had yeah well yeah
well it will get there because it's just
kind of you know cuz at the moment I
just feel like we're we're doing refurbs
and you know we've had planning and this
and he just kind of paying out a lot of
money yeah
so once you know they're kind of one-off
things you've got to pay for but once
all that's done then yeah it will be a
lot better probably you know towards you
know something probably another five six
months it will yeah why are you
properties aware I like so I my first
one I bought after we sold our house was
in High Wycombe yeah it was a rundown
two-bedroom house quite below market
value how much to pay for and we paid
200 - 200 mm yeah refurb a yeah we
briefed up we spent about twenty two
thousand on the retail all in a on two
to four yeah and what's the value now
285 so we refinanced it and we've just
took 200,000 out yeah so that money will
now be used for some of it will be used
for the extension
7th ed yes and then once that's done
then we will refinance that and take
that back out that's great yeah ways to
push the value up so high high high
wycombe which is yeah well it wasn't you
know I wasn't like you know overly
looking to think oh you know like it's
gotta be in High Wycombe it's just that
this house came up I know the area
really well yeah I knew you know because
funny enough with our agent we'd sold
one a few months earlier for 287 like
next door but one so I knew the price of
the house yeah and now that rents really
well the tenants are excellent
I get 1175 rent for that a month great
so we've poured literally most of the
money a new mortgage payments on that in
just only well we the it is interest
only the mortgage payments on that are
gonna be 487 so you pay 487 on the
mortgage payments the rent is 75 1175 so
even with even with maintenance and
management you've got a nice bit of
profit in that
yeah they managed to pull out most nice
money yeah I couldn't account more but I
just left it at 200 there was no need to
take out any more and then after that
then we bought a seven-bedroom HMO and I
used none of my own money on that it was
an investor's money that he put the
money and we got the mortgage yeah and
that's all really well how did you
persuade someone it was a family member
yeah because he knew that I guess you
know what we were doing and he had money
to invest he hasn't you know got any
idea about property and stuff and I put
the idea to him you know I kind of you
know a bit like packaging a deal I said
this this house you know will earn this
much as seven bedrooms
you know we're spread split 50-50 so
he's on to like you know quite a good
you know because a lot of investors you
know they will like maybe pay them like
10% whereas we are splitting that 50/50
you know and he's got like you know it's
all been done
through a solicitor so it's all been
done and she always split the profits on
that and then me and then we then bought
the the seven-bedroom Haitian that
HMO that we're doing at the moment that
it's in Lane and it's quite near Marlow
in Buckinghamshire yeah yeah house
because again we bought that below
market value because houses in that road
they sell for about three twenty five to
sixty because it was been sold through
the council so I managed to you know you
know filled quite a good relationship
with the estate agent and we met because
we bought it cash we were able to secure
it at that price and yeah he's put all
the money into that and then I'm paying
for the refurb yeah so the same person
yeah it's great so you know and again
you know it will be a fifty-fifty he's
got first legal charge on the house but
you know was really interested when you
do it right like from his perspective as
you said he doesn't he doesn't know
anything about investing in people but
because you do it's actually your
knowledge and your experience now which
is which has brought your value value
that you're bringing to the table which
is the deal itself yeah the knowledge
experience is actually just as valuable
as the money that he's bringing to the
table
yeah I'm just the perfect joint venture
yeah well it works really well and that
you know I've I try and you know I'll
give him a statement each month if you
know what what's been the expenditure on
the properties and you know what he gets
and everything is kind of listed for him
you know and I try and kind of simplify
as much as I can because he doesn't want
to get too much into it yeah but I want
to be as like transparent with it you
know so he understands you know
obviously if something goes wrong and
that's why it's been less money that
he's got that month and so on so you've
got one in black ball yeah that wasn't
before yes that's been the last one to
finally complete it completed in
but you've got seven yeah but we've got
we've had three others that we had
before okay
yeah where are those but well it was all
it well one is in Slough yeah and to her
in High Wycombe okay but that was our
family and why kind of we started with
all of this you know originally was
because we sold our family home back
well we didn't sell it actually we were
trying to sell it back in 2011 because I
was pregnant
with Bella and we just couldn't sell the
house in time and obviously we really
wanted to move and we managed to kind of
you know refinance things so we were
able to rent out our family house and
move and then in that six years between
sort of 2011 and sort of mm or 17 the
house price just they just shot up and
we were almost at a point at that point
where we could have paid off our
mortgage in our house where we were
living by selling our original family
home
yeah and threats has said glut my
husband he said well why don't we just
do that then and I said because we're
too young to do that I you know we need
to kind of try and progress with this
and by paying off the mortgage and just
like living happily is it's not my
number of things in the right direction
but you know that's what we're told to
do we're told to work hard save up money
buy a house pay off the mortgage that's
why when I'm talking about rent where
you live yeah investment it freaks
people out yeah like you freaked you out
yeah that's what I just thought this
just sent doesn't sound right but as I
say the more research I did and I
listened to Grant Cardone in one of his
videos he talks a lot about so story he
live same and then there were some other
YouTube things you know channels that I
watched on it and the more I listened to
it I totally got it and my family you
know like they just thought we were
crazy you know there might even my mum
so it's like yeah but you do rent where
you live you know you know you already
renting this house um like yeah
bigger picture it's not like I'm renting
that house and I don't only at any other
houses it doesn't matter that I just
happen to be renting the one where I'm
living
yeah cuz you got seven others yeah and
you're making you're making for over
four thousand a month soon to be doubled
yeah when you actually I know even a
tough few years especially on the health
side the property side hasn't been easy
yeah but actually what you've achieved
is is amazing and not only what you've
achieved financially with the property
but also Bella
who's how old is Bella she's 88 years
old now even she's like getting into it
yeah you brought to the crash goal yeah
she wanted to meet you yeah and she said
sellers comes - what mom Connor comes
this looks like what are you gonna talk
about but yes we should yeah yeah she's
she's she's really into it that yeah she
sees what you're doing yeah and she's
like and I've seen her on videos I've
seen her you know reading my bio rent hi
boys yeah I get out on the viewings yeah
she does she likes it although she
doesn't like some of the houses like
take her to Kansai pretend that we're
gonna move there live in this house the
Oviatt houses make the most money
another thing is interestingly I know
that you you're financially free but
you're choosing to still work but not
that much you work in a few yeah doing
what
working for an estate agent champion
Wickham's
you just love yeah I just love it now
also I just love meeting people and also
like kind of trying to give something
back you know I've met in my job where
you know like people have recently been
left money by you know their parents and
they're looking for investments but
they're not necessarily looking for the
right investments so I was always trying
guide them in the right direction and
saying you know rather than put all your
money into one now is try and spread it
out and then buy several but most most
is there you go to us say if you ask for
investment advice it's all feelings not
formulas yeah and and also it's
interesting that you said you know you
invested before coming to the crash
course and stuff and the house that you
bought
didn't turn out that great because yeah
sometimes people if he's always got
money they'll say I want to put it all
into property and I advocating
you know that's fine okay education and
then the rest in property and I think
you know I mean what would your advice
be like because it's hard for me to sex
people say are you already saying that
because you were a training company mr.
nice I actually believe that and I
actually put my own money in education
yeah I just think there is so much to
learn from you know education and you
know I see it in my job week after week
where you know as I said people just
thinks thinks it's just about buying a
house and renting it out there is so
much more to it you know getting the
right you know rental property and you
know not put all your money into it so I
think it really is important you know
I've been working with someone that you
know I've been advising through work you
know I met him and I've and and he's so
grateful for all the help that I've
given him and it's enabled him now to
buy two properties you know he set up a
limited company you know I've advised
him on that because what he was doing
was all wrong yeah and it's nice to be
able in and he thought well why you
helped me a lot because I just want you
know I would want someone to help me
like you've helped me and I think it's
good to give something back and it
advise people you know if you if you
know something that you know can work
better yeah then then then help people
there's nothing wrong with helping me
and I see you you know you've been
successful you've got a big heart and
and you become friends your friends wife
you helped me move to [ __ ] MC yes I
know I found this house and then you
were like alright okay so yeah we did so
did you find this house and send it to
Amanda I sent it to a map I sent it to
you actually so are you saying and then
I and then I because it was funny cuz
when you move to this house and I saw it
on the video I thought I've seen that
house before and I scrolled back through
our messages and I thought I'd sent you
this house
and of course by the way I was wondering
I rent this house yeah because the same
way that you now rent your house that's
fine actually
so so basically if it wasn't for Andrea
I wouldn't be living in this guy's house
that area yeah because you were looking
at Richmond at the time you guys have
learnt if it beckons field because
obviously you can get to London in sort
and it's not 25 yeah yeah you know it's
really good schools around here kind of
had a little bit you know because I
always end up finding people house is
kind of what I do and I had a little bit
you don't look home right move and I
thought that's a great house your budget
and I was like this would be a great
house and then obviously yeah it was
under budget
yeah what can I say so that's great so
grateful for that I'm sure man yeah more
grateful but yeah so what the plans now
2020 what's the so the plan now is to
get the the house in Blackpool finished
what is it seven flats so we're going to
run three of service accommodation the
other flats are currently rented already
I've got excellent like managing agent
who's helped me immensely with
everything you know he's organised all
the reef he's gone way beyond you know
the help that he's given me with
everything and he runs service
accommodations as well in Blackpool so
he offers quite a bespoke service where
you know he sets all the rooms up and
it's kind of done in a boutique style
power - yeah and yeah how much you
buying the whole block for I paid I paid
a hundred and eighty three thousand
Allah and the owner who bought it in
2011
paid two hundred and ten in 2011 and
they refurbs the whole building we want
it so you've come in and I got it yet
for 183 that's incredible yeah great of
also the mortgage payments are peanuts
on that what what kind of profit we make
on that whole block once it's all done
it'll probably be about three thirty
pens on the surface population it's hard
I've kind of with my figures kind of
done on sore you know a 15 night
occupancy rate yeah profit on that age
month it will probably be about three
thousand six hundred three thousand
seven hundred that's been really
conservative with the you know the
rentals alone would make someone
financially yeah and how much money of
us put into that deal Indians fifty five
thousand so you put fifty five thousand
in making a conservative 3600 I mean the
retail investment like that is ludicrous
yeah and that's why because you could
easily invest fifty five grand let's say
that's all you have in the world it's a
one little single that house that's
gonna make you 300 quid a month yeah you
could easily yeah and people do people
do do it anyhow that's pretty or house
this yeah close by or a house there's
near their grandma's house cuz I think
you'll be here but it's all about
actually what would you say I have all
the things you didn't obviously the
crash course many times she's been on
the advanced training as well what would
you say three most valuable pieces of
information or things that you've
learned would be there served you the
best I think it's just to rip where I
live to be honest that was a funny
moment for me yeah because yeah I think
it obviously without money it makes it
more difficult yeah but you know having
the confidence to kind of go to people
and say well if if I you know if I can
do this if you invest with me then we
can achieve this I think that's another
thing that okay so what is ready when
you live yeah because you somebody gives
you seventh your house gave you a load
of cash Yeah right to is having the
confidence developed to approach joint
venture oh yeah very successful I don't
think talk to me about finding good
deals because before you came on the
cross course you've missed in a bad day
oh now you investing in ridiculously
good deals how do you find good deals I
think that's the thing it teaches you to
how to find the good deals and yeah I
just think it gives you an overall
awareness of what's good and what's
yeah yes so it kind of taught me that
because obviously on the crash course
you learn about you know you know
getting a good ROI on properties and and
yeah and just kind of maximizing the
money that you put into what you can get
out yeah and that's kind of ultimately
what it teaches you whereas on might as
I say all much in my job people just
think oh yeah that's a pretty house I'll
buy that and rent it out yeah do you
think more estate agents should get
educated yeah definitely do my job for
me yeah I don't think they yeah you
don't like say too much no no yeah yeah
I worked as a second for three months
and I think if it's their agents if
every estate agent in the country went
on like crash course solely to be able
to offer good advice to the investors
imagine how much easier would be pick up
the phone to an estate agent and they
got actually and then and they
understand a language and they
understand I think it'd be great I think
there's a stage I'm watching this come
to the crash course just to be able to
add more value investors because look
how much people love you yeah because
they pass on the knowledge yeah and it
has been helpful you know because they
always tend to at work whenever there is
an investor looking at HMOs or certain
properties they tend to send me out
because I can give so much more
information on you know that they're you
know the management side the you know
the license saying what what's required
so my knowledge of that is probably
greater than you know other people that
are just out to think I'll show some
around a house yes but you know what the
more valuable and knowledgeable you
become always the further you'll go in
life and the more money you make
yeah I just joke why she initially went
on the crash course was when you're on
that program
you know the weakness so funny I was
sitting down and I wasn't even looking
at the TV and the program came on and I
thought oh my god who's that oh he's
very enthusiastic and that's when I kind
of stopped and like looked you up and
then thought guy he seems really
interesting and that's
I first went to the crash course because
of that program scry what would you
advise me to someone watching the video
there's wanting to get into property oh
I would say go along for the crash
course read your book
buy low rent my read other books as many
books as you can about property because
you do learn a lot listen to podcasts
yeah I would that's what I'd say really
yeah that's awesome well I'm really
proud of what you've done and it's also
great to be friends and it's great to be
neighbors
yes oh thanks I'm part of the area of
finding the house yeah and I'm looking
forward to seeing how 2020 goes for you
as well
yeah hopefully it will yeah improve by
the end of the year 17 running great job
I hope you enjoyed the interview with
Andrea Harbor she's an amazing person
but here's the thing you gotta get the
knowledge you've got to get the
knowledge so if you're about to invest
in a property please I urge you do not
do it it falls down to the property
investors crash course I will leave a
link in the description you can also get
books on for free there's a one-pound
booking fee with the crash course is
free and you get books on right here I
go ahead go ahead go ahead
see that
[Music]